this one simple thing will save your partner so much heartache
and make them respect and love you more
If your partner comes to you and says “X” is bothering them,
whatever it may be
maybe you're not texting them,
you're not communicating with them,
you're not doing something and it upset them
and they're trying to communicate that to you
what you should do is never disagree or get mad or gaslight them
instead what you should do is simply say..
“I understand why you feel that way and I'm sorry”
it's really that simple
you should never,
ever argue with someone who tells you that you hurt their feelings.
when you argue with your partner
the only thing you'll get out of that is distance and strain in the relationship
you need to come at it at an understanding
respectful way
and this will mean so much more to them
People are so used to being gaslit these days
and made to feel like they're asking for too much
it's not too much for your partner to tell you what problems that they have
there will always be someone who is willing to go
above and beyond for your partner
you don't have to win every argument
or even be in an argument with your partner
Instead you should just come to understand your partner and their needs